vous ne voulez pas parler du passé
je comprends bien naturellement et vous
avez tendance à peu à reprendre le
refrain d'il ya sept ans l'homme du
passé c'est quand même ennuyeux que dans
l'intervalle vous soyez devenu vous
l'homme du passif
cela gêne un peu votre démonstration
d'aujourd'hui
vous m'avez reproché d'avoir exercé
sorte de ministère de la parole mais moi
j'étais dans l'opposition j'ai rempli
mon rôle démocratiquement dans le rige
d'autres et l'opposition ce n'est pas
rien dans une république
j'ajoute que j'ai dû utiliser ce temps
pour faire avec d'autres un grand parti
qui est devenu à partie menaçant pour la
majorité est presque ancienne que vous
représentez aujourd'hui donc je n'ai pas
perdu mon temps aussi ne pouvait faire
pour la france demain à la mesure de la
france bien entendu ce que j'ai pu faire
pour le socialisme en france ma foi ce
ne serait pas perdu